>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
[ Silence ]
>> Jeanne Drewes: Coming to this,
another Preservation Week here
at the Library of Congress.
It started in 2009.
Preservation Week is a national
effort to help inform people
about preservation, and the Library
of Congress was one of
the founding members.
This is our Topics in
Preservation, the 84th,
and I want to just mention the 85th
one that will be happening in May,
on May 22nd, about broken cylinders.
But today's talk is not
about anything that's broken.
Instead, it gives me great pleasure
to finally have Tom Clareson here
at the Library of Congress.
I've actually been trying to get Tom
here to speak on one of his many,
many different projects
for a number of years,
and this year it finally worked out.
So I'm extremely pleased about that.
Tom's the connector.
He connects cultural institutions
in such interesting ways.
And one of those connections is
what you'll hear about today.
I've known Tom for 25 years?
Is that possible?
I don't have gray hair for nothing.
And yet Tom doesn't age.
So there you go.
Tom works for LYRASIS.
He's the senior consultant
both for digital
and preservation services there.
I knew Tom when he started working
at Amigos a number of, 25 years ago.
In 2014 Tom was the
recipient of the George Cunha
and Susan Swartzburg
Award, and that's an award
that recognizes outstanding
leadership in collaboration.
And it was the perfect award for
Tom to get because he collaborates
across all cultural heritage
institutions from museums
to archives to historical
societies and, of course, libraries.
So today we're talking, he's
talking about open arms,
and I think that that really speaks
to what he's been doing
for a very long time.
I was really pleased to
hear his, a similar talk
about this same topic at ALA.
And at that time, I sort of twisted
his arm to come and speak here
at the Library of Congress.
So I couldn't be more
pleased to have him,
and we have how many people viewing
from, we have dozens and dozens
of people on the webinar.
So I want to welcome
all of you as well.
So without further ado, Tom.
[ Applause ]
>> Tom Clareson: Well, thank you,
Jeanne, and thanks to the Library
of Congress for allowing
me to come in and talk
about both the continuation and the
expansion of a couple of programs
that I know some of you
may be familiar with.
But also about the expansion of
disaster preparedness and recovery
into a new field where many of
us in the library, archives,
and museum world have not
had a chance to work before.
So let's see here.
[ Silence ]
What I'd like to talk with you about
today is taking a look at expansion
of disaster preparedness and
recovery across further boundaries
that we have within our field.
Oftentimes we talk about
the silos that we have
between libraries,
archives, and museums.
And as Jeanne has said, I've been
trying to bring that collaboration
about between those
groups for quite a while.
And I've had an opportunity
more recently to work
with even further groups.
So I'm going to give you a little
bit of background on some programs
that have been around
for a couple of years,
but they are actually
expanding quite a bit,
and then go into discussion
of a brand new program.
So new that this is the first
time we've shown the logo
for the program.
So new that the website is
not coming up until Monday.
So it is really something
that we're being able to talk
about a little bit
of breaking news for.
So many of you may be familiar
with the Alliance for Response.
This is a group that has been
working for a number of years
to bring the emergency
management and response community,
those who are always first on the
scene, together with our community,
together with the cultural
heritage community
so that we can actually learn how
to speak each other's language.
This has been something that
has been going on for close
to 15 years now and just
continues and continues to expand.
So it started out with the idea
of building cooperative networks,
the idea of having
people get a chance
to talk before the disaster
happens and introduce each other,
be introduced to each other
before they have to meet outside
of a burning or flooding building.
One of the more interesting things,
and I'll talk about this event
in just a few minutes, was that
I had an opportunity to work
with folks in the Mississippi
Gulf Coast last year,
around April of last year, actually
I think it might have this same
week, and we did our session
for the Alliance for Response.
And the next morning the
speakers who did not leave
that night actually had to find
different ways to the airport
because there was flooding along
the roads, there had been trees
that had been blown
down and knocked down.
So we actually saw people who were
utilizing things that they talked
about and learned about
at the Alliance
for Response meeting the very next
day to make sure that they were safe
and their collections were safe.
The goals.
There are a number of
goals of the Alliance
for Response that are out there.
But the ones that we sort of held as
closely to as possible for a number
of years is this idea of
relationship building.
It might be trading
business cards at first.
It might be even knowing where the
closest emergency management county
office is or which is the closest
fire station to your building,
and to start off with that.
To educate cultural heritage
and emergency management
professionals
and sort of vice versa.
You know, I always take a
look at some of the things
with the incident command system
and many of the other pieces
that the emergency
management world uses.
And oftentimes I figure we've
got an 18-page book of acronyms
that I've got to memorize before
I'm able to work with these folks.
The same thing's happening
with them.
They probably are not as familiar
with some of the care that needs
to happen to our types of materials,
when they're normally looking
at caring for businesses or
caring for houses and maybe not
as familiar with collections.
So that communication
is very important.
And then sustainability.
These ideas of strong, ongoing
networks that are continuing
on to allow people to be educated,
to allow people to continue
to work together for
as long as possible.
So a wide variety of goals.
We started out in 2003, the winter
of, November/December of 2003,
with just a couple of locations,
Boston, Dallas, and I was able
to work with the Cincinnati Art
Museum to host one of the Alliance
for Response conferences there.
A number of years later we
have 28 of these organizations.
And they can be in a
city or a municipal area.
They can also be in
a county or a region.
Most recently, along with the
Mississippi Gulf Coast Alliance
for Response, we have
started to work with Albany
and what's called the
Capital Region up in New York.
So they are really
all over the place.
You'll see there's a few
states missing in the middle
of the country there
where we would definitely
like to get more organizations
started.
But this is something that
has been growing for years
and been very active for years.
Now, the Alliance for Response was
an organization that was started
by Heritage Preservation.
And Heritage Preservation for a
number of years was an organization
that provided advocacy for
preservation, conservation,
did a lot of educational programs.
When that organization finally
shut down in 2015, in May of 2015,
one of the most wonderful
things that I have seen
in my professional life happened,
which was that the Foundation
for the American Institute for
Conservation was actually able
to come in and be able to
support many of the programs
that had been started by
Heritage Preservation.
They've been able to support
them, they've been able
to streamline them, and in
many cases even expand them.
So it was a case where the baton was
passed and the pace was picked up,
and it has been a very good
continuation of a lot of projects.
There are a couple of things
that you can do to find out more
about what are the activities that
are going on all over the country
with Alliance for Response.
You can see that we have the website
here, and that certainly has a lot
of sort of feature stories
about trends that are going
on around the country as
far as disaster preparedness
and recovery are concerned.
But the other thing is, the thing
that I like the most is the fact
that we have this opportunity
to sort of delve in
and see what each network is doing.
And it's actually a great crib
sheet, it's a great CliffNotes
because you can say, well, we
sort of had the same events going
on with our alliance for a while.
What are they doing in San Diego?
What are they doing in
other parts of the country?
So it's a way to sort of refresh
our curriculum for what's happening
with the Alliance for
Response activities.
So there have been
plenty of successes.
I didn't want to have five
or six slides on this.
I tried to boil it down to one
slide, but we have had some
of the groups that have been around
for quite a long time like Atlanta,
establishing a listserve that
includes emergency responders.
And I've been parts of
alliances where we've had one
or two emergency responders on them.
But this is one where there is
great give and take that work
with the emergency
responders quite a bit.
Now, I'm not sure how they're
handling the parts of the road
that are falling apart
down in Atlanta,
but I know that that is something
that is certainly causing havoc
for the arts and culture community.
So that may be something that
they're going to have to deal with.
Boston, which has been around since
2003, got a hazard mitigation grant
that was awarded by the Federal
Emergency Management Agency,
but also Massachusetts
to provide training at
the community level.
So they were actually doing
quite a bit of training
on incident command
system and other areas.
Galveston and Houston
that have worked together
for a long time had a disaster
planning webinar to try to get
as many people in their offices
working on disaster plans
and has also held some incident
command system training.
And then New York is
one of the places
where this model has
actually worked the best.
And unfortunately it was
because of a bad situation.
They worked with the Office of
Emergency Management of New York
in conference calls to get updates
on what the city was doing during
Hurricane Irene and Hurricane Sandy.
And then the Alliance
for Response got a grant
from the New York Community Trust
to train heritage responders;
to develop a website
and identification
and inventory information; to
provide social media feeds;
and document, map, and try to
figure out where the damage
to the culture community was.
So it was really interesting
to see all of the activities
that this group has done.
Currently, another
group that is active,
quite active every year is the
Denver Alliance for Response
because of the wildfires that
are happening in Colorado.
So they have folks from the forestry
areas, emergency management,
and the cultural heritage
institutions working together.
So many, many successes for the
Alliance for Response program.
I also wanted to talk, and there
are a number of people who are
in the room that are part of this,
about the National
Heritage Responders program.
And this is a program that has
come from the American Institute
for Conservation as well.
And it actually is one where there
are a couple of components to it.
One of the major components is
being on the end of that phone line
that we just saw in bold face and
having people who can be online
or on the phone to talk you
through a disaster that might happen
at your individual institution.
Is there part of your collection
that may have been
damaged in some way?
Is there a concern because your
building is not providing the
envelope it could or should
to protect the collections?
So we have that level of
discussion that can happen.
And I know that Jeanne Drewes has
done a number of tours of duty
on the phone during that,
and Andrew Robb as well.
Many of you in this room have helped
on the National Heritage
Responders side of things.
This group has been active,
again, for close to ten years.
It started as a result
of the Hurricane Katrina
and Hurricane Rita in 2005.
People felt that there was
a need to have a network
of responders around the country.
And so in 2007, and again
in 2011, there was training
that was made available,
very advanced training,
actually on-site training,
going through complete aspects
of a mock disaster in an
organization and figuring out all
of the activities that could be used
for a variety of format
of materials.
But also the other thing that was
really quite interesting for me
as one of the trainees was the level
of documentation that they asked us
to put together in this training.
So between those two
trainings, between the 2007
and 2011 training sessions, the
first of which was sponsored
by IMLS, they actually have
trained over 100 people.
I think it's about 107 folks who
are trained at this point to be able
to respond to these
types of disasters.
Like I said, this can be done over
the phone, but the other thing is
that the group can be deployed.
Small groups or small teams of
people can be deployed to a number
of locations around the country.
So when we have a region-wide
disaster, when we have situations
like the floods that occurred in
North Dakota and seemed to happen
on an almost annual basis
there, the earthquake in Haiti,
a number of situations
like Superstorm Sandy
and other hurricanes, there is
the ability to get people on site
and get people who
know, know conservation
and who have been trained in how
to deal with this type of activity,
who have been trained to document,
who have been trained
how to communicate.
So this is a really
important collaborative team
that I hope we don't
have the opportunities
to use much, but I
know that we will.
So it's an important
backing team that is there.
But what I'm really here to talk
about, in addition to talking
with you about the safety net that's
out there through the Alliance
for Response and National
Heritage Responders,
is what's happening
in the arts community.
There have been a variety of
situations that we've had to think
about and talk about
in the arts community.
This is actually on campus
at the University of Iowa,
some of the flooding
that they have had.
Again, a state that has very
regular schedules, unfortunately,
of flooding where they have to
deal with this type of situation.
And this was the performing arts
center there getting damaged.
One of the things that has been,
I think, the most disheartening
but also one of the biggest call
to arms was the Ghost Ship fire
that happened in December of
2016 where an arts collective
in the Oakland, California, area
burned and there were 36 people
who passed away in that fire.
And one of the things
that we're looking at is,
we look at this all the time is,
the human safety, the human aspect
of trying to make sure, before
anything else, that the staff,
the patrons, the guests,
the audience is safe.
So we need to think about floods,
we need to think about fire,
but we also need to think about
things that are as seemingly mundane
as digital disasters as well.
And with the activities that
we do in the library world,
we certainly have digital
collections that can be damaged.
But one of the things that we have
learned when we've been working
with the performing arts
community is the level of concern
about the ticket lists,
the seating lists,
information about productions,
etc., that are online and the fact
that we need to make sure
that those are saved as well.
So we're looking at a
wide variety of disasters.
And one of the things that the folks
in the emergency management
community talk
about all the time
is all hazards types
of disaster preparedness
and recovery.
And we want this to be all
hazards not just thinking
about natural hazards,
man-made hazards,
but also mechanical hazards as well.
These digital disasters can be
really a difficult situation
for an organization, too.
So we're trying to cover
all of these areas.
So we had an opportunity to talk
in the fall of 2015 with a group
of the leaders on a
regional and national basis
in the performing arts world.
And the Mellon Foundation
brought a number of organizations
that were leaders in
the preservation
and conservation regional community
together with their counterparts
in the performing arts community.
And one of the things that
we heard was that there were,
in a lot of cases there
were collections,
but there were also a lot of
other things that we had to think
about when we were thinking about
working with and responding along
with the performing
arts organizations.
So after a disaster, think about the
kind of things that might happen.
Think about -- and this was a
situation that definitely happened
in 2001 when Tropical Storm
Allison sat over Houston
and dumped 21 inches of rain over
three days, and part of it was
on a theater complex there --
what will happen to
the building and venue?
Could it be collapsed walls?
What will happen to the sets?
What will happen to the
costumes, which may be something
that is stored for a long time by
the organization or may be something
that is traveling along
with the presenting group?
The records, the business records,
the tickets records,
are important as well.
The concern that we heard from the
performing arts community, though,
the biggest thing that they asked us
to look at was the loss of business,
the fact that if they had a
disaster, if they had a fire,
the doors were going to be shut and
that performance could not go on.
And recovering from lost revenue.
So what was an area of interest
that they were wanting to see
if it could be provided was,
continuity of operations
and continuity of business
assistance and training
and disaster preparedness
assistance and training as well.
In 2016, in the beginning of
2016, my organization, LYRASIS,
received a six-month, Andrew W.
Mellon Foundation planning grant.
And there were five preservation
and conservation organizations
and four performing
arts organizations
that worked together on this grant.
We reviewed existing
surveys, existing research
that had been done on this topic.
And one of the things that we
found, which was a concern was,
there wasn't a lot
that was out there.
There were not some of
longitudinal surveys
that some states have been doing.
There were not the kind
of studies that had come
through the IMLS Connecting
to Collections program
or the National Endowment for the
Humanities Field Services programs
that are out there, that
are taking the temperature
of what disaster planning has been
going on for years in the field.
So there were not as many of those.
But there were new surveys.
There's an annual survey done
by one of the leader groups
in the field called the National
Performance Network, or NPN,
and they had been doing a couple of
different surveys really every year
to take a look at what their members
around the country were seeing
as far as the need for disaster
preparedness and planning.
And we looked at that research, we
also did some of our own research.
We went to New Orleans and talked
with a group at NPN's headquarters.
In Red Bank, New Jersey, we
were at the Count Basie Theatre
between two performances that
I wish I'd been able to go to.
But I was able to, to lead
the focus group there.
The New Jersey State Council on
the Arts, which is really a leader
as far as one of the
statewide organizations that is
out there focusing on the arts,
was able to provide a
situation for us to talk there.
In Austin, Texas, I walked into
the middle of a construction zone
where the Dance/USA
Conference was being held.
And we talked over jackhammers and
a lot of other construction noise
and debris about the kind of things
that we needed to look at as far
as working with the dance
community and other parts
of the performing arts community.
And then we were able to actually
get a virtual focus group as well.
Another thing that we did was looked
at the disaster preparedness tools
that are out and available for both
the cultural heritage community
and for the performing arts
community and do some comparisons.
What did they cover?
Where were they missing things?
Where were the blanks
that they were having?
What we found, through the survey
research that we looked at,
was that a majority of performing
arts organizations did not have
disaster plans, and even fewer had
continuity of operations plans.
Planning really is not an
institutional priority.
They have to get the show
going on for the next period.
They have to think about other
shows that are coming up.
They need to think about
actually a lot of day-to-day work,
and they need to, you know,
their collections, in some cases,
their collections can be the
performers who are coming together
as a troupe to prevent,
present something.
And so the planning might not be as
much of an institutional priority.
They don't have the time
or expertise to do this,
and they may have small staffs.
We talked, especially the Dance/USA
Conference, I talked with a number
of organizations with a staff size
of one or one and a half people.
So that was difficult
to think about.
One of the things that I was
very pleased about, though,
that I couldn't believe it the
first time I heard it at one
of the focus groups, and I had to
ask at every one after that was,
what's happening with
your electronic records.
And many of the organizations
were saying that they are stored,
as well as being backed up on
site, they're stored off site.
They're stored in the cloud.
They were thinking of some
levels of digital preservation
or digital disaster planning so that
they were not completely crippled
by a situation where their
records might be taken
out by a storm or other problems.
So just very quickly, taking a
quick look at the NPN information,
the majority of the partners
didn't have an emergency plan,
and it wasn't an institutional
priority.
Some groups were unaware of the need
for a plan, didn't have the time
to do it, didn't have the expertise,
or said that they couldn't
afford to develop a plan.
That became a really important
part of the grant project
that we are working on now to try
to make some level of infrastructure
for planning available
to these organizations
without a huge charge,
without a cost to them.
And in some cases, without monetary
cost to them, but also looking
at trying to take the stress
of the personnel cost a little
bit off of them as well.
We worked with organizations
that were both producing
and presenting organizations.
And the difference here is that the
producing organizations may be the
group that creates and
stages some of the work,
where the presenting organizations
may be theaters that bring in works
that are produced by others,
works that are created by others.
But we also found that there are
a lot of organizations that serve
in both of these types
of activities.
We work with organizations
with and without facilities.
And I think one of the things that
really gave me the biggest shock
when I was talking with one of the
focus groups was an organization
that said they regularly perform
at six different institutions,
six different buildings a year.
And they said, we don't know
anything about those institutions.
We don't know their disaster plans,
if they have a disaster plan,
we had to walk around and figure out
where the entries and exits were.
We had to walk around to figure out
where the fire extinguishers were
or if there's even a fire
suppression system at all.
They're walking into these
situations and, you know,
it's a concern because they
don't know even the first level
of safety activities
related to these.
So the organizations
without facilities really
made their voices known
to us as needing some help.
Can you help us put together a
checklist on what we should hope
and expect that our host
organizations will provide us
in the future?
Their definition of a
disaster, a little bit different
than we might have at the Library
of Congress, National Archives,
or the Smithsonian Museums.
It's, in some cases, yes,
a disruption of business.
It's something that all
of us are concerned about.
But a forced performance
cancellation.
Is this a situation where you
had a performance on the books,
it's been on the books
for nine months or a year,
and because of this disaster
you've had to cancel it.
And then what can the
financial repercussions be?
When we talked to the few
organizations that came
to the focus groups that did have
disaster plans, what they said was
that the plans that they had were
focused on just a couple things,
human safety, getting people out,
evacuating folks, and
communications.
Communications on what the staff,
what the next artist who was doing
and should do because
the building was damaged.
Few had the actual
continuity of operations
and continuity of business plans.
It was mainly some of the quick
communications that could happen.
What they said they needed
was information on resources
and best practices for both planning
for and recovery from disasters.
Few have had any type of
disaster training, and that is one
of the things that's really
important within this program
that we're developing to make
sure these organizations get.
So they were interested in
preparedness and recovery training,
both being able to put the
plans together and then,
after the incident does
happen, what can they do.
Working with existing networks
in performing arts
and cultural heritage.
So working with some of the
28 groups that were out there
from the Alliance for Response.
Working with organizations
like Culture Aid in New York,
which is more with the performing
and visual arts type of background.
And then another thing that,
again, was interesting to me,
and this was the part that I really
appreciated the most, I think,
out of any of the focus
groups that we did.
At the Count Basie Theatre, we
had people coming up and saying,
all right, our performing
arts organization is going
to have next year its
75th anniversary.
And what we have with our programs,
with our performance histories,
our photographs, our business
records, is that they are --
one organization said
they're in tubs under the bed
of the various different
board of directors members,
spread all over town
or all over the county.
Or they might be in
the basement as well.
And so we said, you
know, what can we do?
How can we think about this idea of
archiving organizational history,
production records, history,
programs, photographs, etc.?
So what has come of this is, we had
our planning grant June through,
January through June of
2016 and then took some time
to put together an
implementation grant
that was awarded last December.
This is called the Performing
Arts Readiness Project,
and it started in January of 2017.
It's a three-year project funded
by the Andrew Mellon Foundation.
And one of the best things
that we did right off the bat
with this grant was that we
were able to even the sides up,
even the discussion up, and bring
the Performing Arts Alliance,
or PAA, into the project.
And the Performing Arts
Alliance is actually a group,
an alliance of associations
and groups that already deal
with performing arts disciplines.
And so this was a group that had a
very wide reach, a national reach,
an across-the-field reach.
So you'll see a wide variety
of organizations here.
And I wanted to talk about each of
them just in case you can't read all
of them, give you a minor
background on all of them.
Of course, my organization,
LYRASIS, there is a project,
a program called Arts Ready
that comes out of South Arts,
which is one of the regional
performing arts group.
And so Arts Ready is actually a
disaster planning tool that has been
around for a number of years and
that these organizations have used
and become members of
to do disaster planning.
The Conservation Center in
Philadelphia is another member.
The Midwest Art Conservation
Center in Minneapolis.
We have the National Performance
Network based in New Orleans
but members around the country.
Each state that is represented on
our webinar and many of the states
that you work closely
with has an arts council.
And the New Jersey State Council
on the Arts actually was brought
to my attention because they were
the first performing arts group
to join with and work with and
be on the steering committee
of an alliance for response.
When the New Jersey
Alliance for Response, NJCAR,
the New Jersey Cultural Alliance
for Response, started three
or four years ago, they actually
had a performing arts organization
at the table, and it was the
State Council on the Arts.
So we asked one of their
lead people to be a member
of our partner group as well.
Northeast Document Conservation
Center, or NEDCC, is another group.
We are funded, as I said,
by the Mellon Foundation.
We work with WESTPAS,
the Western States
and Territories Preservation
Advisory [sic] Service,
which is more of a virtual
preservation service than a bricks
and mortar regional group.
They do a lot of training,
education,
and response in the
western part of the U.S.
And then the Performing
Arts Alliance.
So we have a really wide
variety and an excellent variety
of groups to work with here.
So this is a huge grant.
We wanted to try to
do as many things
as we possibly could
to help this community.
We may have gone a
little bit overboard,
but I think we're finding strengths
within all of the organizations
that we're working with in
order to be able to do this.
As I said before, really
important aspect to bracket this,
working with producing and
presenting organizations,
not just one or the other.
Working with organizations
with and without facilities.
But we're doing a lot of
outreach, community engagement,
sort of getting people to think
about the need for
disaster planning.
We're providing information
resources, the good things that are
out there already and the
things like those checklists
that people might be talking
about if they are doing activities
in buildings that they
are not usually housed in.
Training and conference programming.
Templates and tools.
And this is going to be one of
the bigger aspects of what comes
out of this program, and I'll talk
about that in just a few minutes.
One of my favorites, and
actually I want you all to think
about is this something that
should happen in the district,
is a circuit rider project.
And then we're actually going to
be able to give grants, sub-grants,
for disaster networks and
for disaster planning.
So I'm going to talk and provide
just a few details on each of these
so you can see the
breadth of the program.
The outreach and community
engagement.
We're doing conference
presentations all over the country.
The first time I took a look at
the list of conference that are
out there for the performing arts
community I wasn't familiar with any
of the organizations,
and I said, oh,
I have to get educated
on this really quickly.
There are about 30 conferences
that are out there, probably more,
that happen -- this is on a
regional and national basis,
not just the state basis, and so
we're looking at where can we meet
and work with some of these
associations at their conferences.
And especially working with
some of the regional groups
like South Arts and
NPN has been good.
Meeting with key stakeholders.
Just opportunities
to talk with a number
of performing arts
groups in key cities.
I was attending a conference by
the Pennsylvania Governor's Office
of Homeland Security
on large event security
and large event disaster
planning and had an opportunity,
just a week before that was
put together, to start working
with the Greater Pittsburgh Arts
Council, who pulled together some
of their key players and brought
them together the day before
so we could talk about how
this program could work well
in Pittsburgh.
So it was interesting to see
that type of planning going on,
and we hope to continue
that in as many cities
and counties as possible.
Trusted information resources.
As I mentioned, links to existing
resources and creating things
that are new for the field.
And I will sort of do a
little bit of promotion here.
We have a website coming in
early May, hopefully next week,
that is going to talk a little
bit more about our program,
provide links to a wide variety of
things that are already out there,
but is also going to give
you both some background
on what happened during our planning
project and a future forecast
of the kind of activities that
we'll be doing during the rest
of the project.
We have a variety of workshops.
In May or June we're going to
start offering on a monthly basis,
and in some cases bimonthly
basis, an introduction
to emergency preparedness webinar.
What are some of the key things
that performing arts
organizations would need to know?
What are some of the key resources?
So that's starting soon.
And then we're going to branch
out into a series of two-hour
or four-hour in-depth webinars
and some in-person classes.
And actually the steering committee,
our group, our partner group,
has said we would much rather
get out there and do as many
of these in-person
classes as we possibly can.
We like to do the webinars,
but it has been so good
through the focus groups and
through some of presentations
that we've done already to see the
level of interest that is out there
that we would like to do as many
of these in person as possible.
So we're going to look
at some of the topics
that you might think of
in disaster planning.
Risk assessment and mitigation.
What is the possibility of
this risk causing damage
to this performing
arts organization?
Basics of business continuity plans,
disaster response,
mutual support networks.
How can some of the performing
arts groups take advantage
of the networks that
are already out there?
Venue safety and security.
This is the hot topic.
And we can't get this
class ready fast enough.
And, in fact, we're actually
working with a number of conferences
where they said, even if you
come here and do 45 or 50 minutes
on venue safety and
security, we want you to come
to our 2017 conferences and put
together a program fast for us.
What they're concerned
about is active shooters.
What they're concerned about is
situations that might cause concern
for the audience and the
performers while they are on stage
or while they are doing
some type of activity.
So that venue safety and
security is very important.
Health and human safety.
And then community
recovery assistance.
Actually, when I was first
starting to talk about this,
I was saying safe havens.
The idea that we would have
safe havens for people.
And they said, oh, maybe it would be
a little bit better to talk about it
in different terminology and
sort of a wider perspective.
What we're looking at, and this
is something that also drew my eye
to New Jersey, and this is,
they have a model there
that is really amazing.
Both the libraries, and many of you
might have heard of a conference,
it was called Ports in the
Storm where they talked
about the libraries being areas
where people could gather,
where FEMA staff could gather,
where there were FEMA meetings held.
That was really important.
And we were at a statewide
meeting in New Jersey talking
about how great this program was,
and all of the folks who were there
from the performing
arts organizations said,
we've been doing the
same things, too.
We have been having FEMA
meetings in our lobbies.
We have been letting people come in
and use every single electric plug
in our whole facility
because we've had our,
oftentimes they have gotten
their power restored quickly,
to charge their cell phones.
We use this as meeting spots.
We use these as spots to talk
about what needs to be done as far
as community planning,
community meetings with FEMA.
So building these community recovery
assistance networks is going
to be important as well.
And then the last topic here
is one that we learned of
and probably would not
have thought of at all
if we hadn't had those focus groups
with the archiving
and records retention.
I had an opportunity to work in New
Jersey end of November beginning
of December of last year with
the State Council on the Arts,
and we had full-day in-person
classes and actually,
using a performing arts term,
as least one of them
was standing room only.
And we were able to talk with about
60 or 70 different organizations
about basics in disaster planning,
and it was very well received.
A lot of continuing
conversation for that.
And again, the need for the classes
to address traveling organizations
without a facility
is important as well.
We want to look at some of
the disaster planning tools
that we surveyed when we were
doing our research and think
about what can be done with
those tools as we go forward.
So many of you might be
familiar with the PReP tool,
the pocket response plan.
Two sides of a sheet of paper,
and it gives you some
contact information
and then initial steps to take.
And it can include floor plans
and include other information
about your building.
Can that be utilized
for the performing arts?
We're still working on that.
It is something where I don't think
it's going to be like the PReP plan,
that WESTPAS and so many other
groups have actually done
so well in training people on.
We need to actually sort of morph
this and see if it can be used
for the performing arts community.
ArtsReady, the tool for
performing arts preparedness.
That is a tool that has been
around for a bit of time.
South Arts, who is the parent
organization for ArtsReady,
wants to make some
changes in the project.
The other project that many
of you might be familiar
with is the Northeast Document
Conservation Center's dPlan tool,
which is sort of a
fill-in-the-blanks type
of disaster planning
tool that's out there.
And dPlan has been around for now
probably 12, maybe 15 years as well,
and it is ready for
some enhancements.
So we're looking at the idea of, can
there be enhancements made to both
of these so they both can be
applicable to both types of,
parts of the arts and culture field.
And is there any possibility,
and we're seeing
that we think there may be some,
for the tools to work together
and provide some, some accelerated
and enhanced help to the community.
And the last thing that we're trying
to do, and it really is an idea
that has come from the
insurance industry,
is something called a
loss of income calculator.
If you have this many seats
and a disaster cancels
this many performances,
what kind of loss of
income do you have?
Is this a need, going to
show a need for insurance?
Is it going to show a need
for disaster planning?
For the idea of a plan b or back-up
site to hold your performance?
So those are some things
we're thinking of for tools.
And then I mentioned the
Circuit Rider program.
This is going to be a person
who is going to be able
to provide local training.
They're going to go around to 25
to 30 organizations in their area
and help them develop disaster
plans that are tailored
to that individual organization.
If there is a disaster in the
area, they're going to be able
to provide assistance
when those happen.
And so we've got two organizations
that are starting actually
in July with these projects.
The first one is in northeast Ohio
and the Cleveland area,
ICA Art Conservation.
And it used to be the Intermuseum
Conversation Association
but has now changed their name.
ICA Art Conservation is
going to be the host group
for one of the circuit riders.
And in New Jersey the State
Council for the Arts is going
to be a host group for a
circuit rider who's going
to cover the whole state.
So that's going to be
somebody who's going
to put a lot of mileage
on their car.
So we've got those two locations.
These are based on some
very successful operations
that are going on in Massachusetts.
If you haven't heard about this, my
friend and colleague Rachel Onuf,
who is in Massachusetts, has put
together a circuit riding program
to look at preservation and archival
practices for city governments,
town governments, townships,
and other organizations as well.
So she does sort of circuit
riding around the commonwealth
to help them develop those plans.
And as of next month, in fact, I
think as of early as next week,
she's going to be doing
this in Vermont as well.
And she is going to be able to show
us the blueprint of what she does
and give us some training
on what's happening there.
So this bottom point that I would
like you to be especially cognizant
about is, there's an opportunity
for four Circuit Rider programs
from July of 2018 to June of 2019.
And I'm hoping that those of you who
are on the webinar and those of you
who are in the room, if you
feel that there might be a need
because of the density of
performing arts groups in your city,
in your region, that it might
be something that you could look
at for the Circuit Rider program.
So I'll talk about that in
just a few minutes as well.
And then the last area, but one
that is quite important as well,
is that we are going to
be providing sub-grants.
We're going to be providing grants
from the original grant that we got.
So we're going to be looking
at enhancing existing
disaster networks.
We have 10 to 12 grants that
we're going to give out on a level
of $7,500 each to groups
like CultureAID,
to groups like the
Alliance for Response,
to make sure that their
programming is able to be inclusive
of the performing arts, to make
sure that their membership,
their communications, is able to be
inclusive of the performing arts.
So we're really pleased
about doing that.
And at the meeting that Jeanne was
talking about at ALA Midwinter,
it was kind of amazing because we
had six or seven cities or areas
that said we want to
do one of those grants.
And boy, get your guidelines
out right now.
The guidelines, unfortunately, will
not be out until July or August,
but we are hoping to actually
go through the whole process
and be able to award those in
December of this year or January
of next year to some of these
existing disaster networks.
We're developing two
new disaster networks.
In some cases, they can take
the models that are out there,
like the Alliance for Response or
other groups, and they will be able
to utilize funding, $15,000
each for two organizations,
to start the whole
infrastructure of planning,
to put together what we call
the initial forum that Alliance
for Response groups have where they
really have a full day conference
on emergency preparedness
and cultural heritage
in a city or county or region.
And so there are a number of groups
who are looking at this as well.
We've had inquiries from New
Orleans and the New Orleans area
and inquiries from
some of the cities
in northern New Mexico
potentially getting together
to do some activities this way.
And then finally, we have
individual institution disaster
planning assistance.
That is being able to provide
consulting and expertise
to help these institutions
build their own plans.
When they said we don't
have the expertise on staff,
when they said we don't
have the time or the staff,
can we bring in people from
the field to assist them
in developing these plans?
Can we provide them some training?
Can we get them to training
that is beyond our program
but might be bringing in things
like active shooter training
or other types of activities
that they need to know about,
and can we help them
get some of the tools,
and this is the actual
equipment-type tools
or it can be some of planning
tools that are out there,
and help them utilize those for
their organizations as well.
So we're going to have up to 40 of
those grants around $7,250 each.
And so, again, we are looking
forward to getting the guidelines
for these programs out
there as soon as possible.
So where can libraries help?
Where can you all help?
These are the areas where I'd
really like you to be thinking
as you go away from
this presentation.
Can you identify performing arts
organizations in your community
that need assistance, could utilize
some of the information that is
out there, could utilize the
education topics that we talked
about and use some of
the planning grants?
Can you identify cities, states,
or regions that have that density
of performing arts organizations
that some, some cities have
where I've worked in New jersey,
worked in Pennsylvania, in Ohio,
where we have two very well
known performing arts communities
within just blocks of each other.
Two, four, six of them.
Is there another area
with that kind of density
for the round two Circuit Rider
programs, and can your organization,
could the Library of Congress,
could another organization
that's represented here today,
think about co-hosting
one of these types
of groups in the future as well?
Workshop and conference
presentations.
I know that some of you teach
about and talk about conservation
and preservation and disaster
preparedness all the time.
We would be very interested in
working with you if you feel
that you have information
that would be of help
to the performing arts community,
that could become part of some
of the workshops that
we've been talking about.
Consider expanding the
disaster networks in your area.
Or are there metropolitan areas
that need a disaster network?
And then collaborating
with performing arts groups
on those community recovery efforts
during emergencies and disasters.
Get introduced to them now, do
the business card trading now,
go to their theater now to find out
how you and they can work together
as community shelters, as those
havens for people to work with
and meet at during disasters.
And promoting the program in your
community starting now as well.
So that is actually the
extent of my presentation.
I did think of one thing as I
was preparing to talk about this.
Some of you might ask why is
an organization that has worked
for years and years in its many
forms, SOLINET, PALINET, NELINET
and other networks that got
together in 2009 to form LYRASIS,
why is this organization that's
worked with libraries and archives,
and more recently with
museums, starting to work
with the performing arts?
You know, how did that come about?
And really, what we're looking at
is trying to do whole community type
of disaster preparedness
and recovery.
The idea of working with all of
the arts and cultural organizations
within a community to help them set
up networks but to help them recover
and help them continue to be open
for the members of the community
that are out there who might need
to do research at a library archive
or a museum or who might
need to actually take a break
from the recovery that
they're going through,
if their house has been
damaged, and see what's going
on with the performing arts.
We want to make sure that we're
trying to cover as much of the arts
and culture provider
community with some basic level
of disaster preparedness and
recovery information as possible.
So that's where our organization
that has a long history starting
out as SOLINET, publishing,
being on site,
and working with other organizations
in disaster preparedness has decided
to move forward with these
wonderful, nine other partners
that we're working with
to mount this program.
So we are in the very
early days of this program.
We are still sort of chugging
along getting a lot of the parts
of the program started up.
I think that especially by
this fall you'll be hearing
about the grants coming out, you'll
be hearing about some of the things
that the circuit riders are doing
with the turn of the
calendar in 2018.
You'll hear more about what
enhancements are happening
with the disaster preparedness
and recovery tools.
And so please keep a
watch out on this program.
And one of the things that
I thought was great was,
we had a terrible time kicking
around names for this program.
And some of the acronyms
just didn't work out.
We were trying to figure out, you
know, what we could call the program
and the performing arts readiness.
Having the performing arts community
be ready for a disaster is good.
But it also presents
a nice play on words.
What we are doing with the workshops
and allowing people to develop plans
and have some level of grants
and support for their plans is,
we are Performing Arts Readiness.
So with that, I wanted to see
if there are any questions
or any other feedback that you
might have about the program so far.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Jeanne.
>> Jeanne Drewes: So, Tom, you maybe
said this and I didn't catch it.
What is the length of
time for this program?
Is it --
>> Tom Clareson: It's three years.
>> Jeanne Drewes: It's three years.
>> Tom Clareson: Yes.
It's a three-year grant from the
Mellon Foundation that we have.
So we are actually, with some of
the individual institution grants,
we're hoping to offer two rounds
of those, two rounds of 20.
With the network grants,
we'll probably offer the new
network grants at the very beginning
because there needs to be
some buildup for those.
But we may offer two
rounds of five or six
of the enhanced network
grants as well.
Other questions?
Yes, Mary.
>> You said something about maybe
you guys got a little bit too eager
in developing these programs.
And so what did you mean by that?
>> Tom Clareson: You know,
we saw so many avenues
where we wanted to
provide assistance.
And I think that we
were trying to look
at how many different components
we can provide to people.
And we put this together
in our grant proposal,
and we actually have a great sort
of timeline and plan for rolling
out these aspects of things.
But it has been very
interesting for the preservation
and conservation organizations
that are involved.
And in some ways I
think we felt like, oh,
we've been doing emergency
preparedness
and disaster response
for years and years.
This should be something
where we can, you know,
fit this emergency preparedness,
disaster plan box, with another type
of organization, with
another level of organization.
And I've got to tell you, within
the first couple of days of starting
to meet with folks from the
performing arts organizations,
they were, like, yeah
we have collections,
but we're not as interested
in those collections
as we are interested in the people.
We're interested in
the performances.
We're interested in the
idea of the show must go on.
And so we had to really learn
a lot of the, the interests
and the driving needs of this area.
We had to learn their
language as well,
learn the organizations
that were out there.
So it was quite a learning curve.
And that has, it's
been relatively steep,
but I think that it has been really
eye opening for all of the folks
from the preservation
and conservation centers
who are out there.
And the other thing that is
great for me that I really love,
and I like, I look for this in
all the challenges that I take on,
and we look for this
in a lot of challenges
that my organization takes on.
This is not something where
its 75 percent coming from the,
the preservation and
conservation community and 25
from the performing arts community.
On a daily basis it's, we
might be providing 51 percent
of the knowledge, and
then you have 49,
and then it flip-flops the next day.
And so it is much more of a
two-way street than I think any
of the organizations expected when
we first started out the program.
So it's a, it really is
open arms, and we're having
to open our arms very wide to make
sure we work with as many aspects
of the community as
possible and can provide
as much programmatic
support as possible as well.
So it's, I think the learning curve
is something that has sort of been,
you know, eyes bigger
than your stomach type
of situation that we've had.
But I think it is going well,
the research is going on well.
Andrew [assumed spelling].
>> Yeah, I have a question
about, you know, you were talking
about some of these organizations
have really small numbers of people.
>> Tom Clareson: Yes.
>> And I'm curious a
little bit about, like,
what you found the range
of the sizes of, you know,
if it was typically less
than three, typically less
than four, and people are ten.
You know, what sort of,
what that sweet spot was.
>> Tom Clareson: Right.
>> also in relation to that,
I can see another issue
where there may just be,
particularly with the smaller
institutions, a real problem
with continuity of staff.
>> Tom Clareson: Yes.
>> That particularly for
the, like you've described
as the non the non-producing --
>> Tom Clareson: Right.
>> -- performers --
>> Where it may turn
over very quickly.
And I can see that being
a particular challenge
where there isn't that
continuity that you might have
in a collecting institution
just because you don't,
if you have a building and it kind
of stays there, and even if --
>> Tom Clareson: Right.
>> -- people move, the
stuff doesn't move.
>> Tom Clareson: Right.
>> In this case you have a real,
if you have that real
loss of continuity.
>> Tom Clareson: And we do
see quite a bit of difference
between the organizations that
do and don't have a facility.
Some of the traveling organizations
that might not have a facility
do have a much smaller staff
and infrastructure of people.
And so they have especially
said, you know, we need to think
about how we can deal
with these situations.
And we need to think about when
we're going into another facility,
how to deal with these situations.
In some cases we are
working with some
of the performing arts
centers that are out there.
And when I was doing my classes
in New Jersey one of the things
that I was most pleased was that,
sort of the sweet spot in working
with many of these organizations is,
if they have an operations
manager, we're golden.
If they have an operations
manager who knows the building,
who knows a lot of the businesses,
who knows a lot of the technology
and things, that is very helpful.
So it is a really wide
range, though.
We're working with organizations
that may have 15 to 20 people
on staff, and we really need to look
at what can happen from everything
to building and community
disasters with them
to these non-facility organizations
that may have two or three people,
may have one and a half people
like some of those that came
to a couple of our focus group.
And what we're suggesting with them
is to try to work collaboratively
with other performing arts groups,
to try to work collaboratively,
even with other cultural heritage
groups who might be able to help.
Because that's the same thing we
do with some of the smaller museums
and historical societies.
When I go out and I'm working
with a number of states,
when they are that small, it's
going to be difficult in some cases
for them to even get to the
building and get into the building.
And if there's heavy damage,
certainly it's not going
to be something that
one person can do.
So that's important as well.
So those are one of, sort of a main
area or dividing line that I see
for different levels of service
that we need to have out there.
Yes.
>> So with the workshops
and the individual systems,
are you also reaching out
to the emergency managers
that are associated with the cities
those cultural organizations are --
>> Tom Clareson: We are.
>> -- performing arts organizations
are in and connecting them
as part of the workshop, or?
>> Tom Clareson: Yes.
Yes. And one of the
best locations, I think,
because they've had almost ten
years of doing this for the Alliance
for Response, has been Pittsburgh.
They've had a very active Alliance
for Response group
for years and years.
And they are making ties already
with the performing
arts organizations
who themselves have been
networking a little bit.
And they have people from
Allegheny County and their region,
Region 13 Emergency Preparedness and
Recovery area, that have been part
of Alliance for Response.
And they're saying now that Alliance
for Response may be expanding a bit
in the Pittsburgh area to include
performing arts organizations.
Yes, they certainly want to be
there to work with organizations
that may have more people
than books inside their walls,
that may have more people than
artworks inside their walls.
So we're definitely
trying to do that.
I think, and I'm going to be really
candid here, that the Alliance
for Response groups around the
country always need to be recruiting
and working with emergency managers.
You know, I would love to see what
I saw in Mississippi when we worked
with the Gulf Coast program
and there were more emergency
response folks in the room
than there were cultural
heritage folks
in the room at that kickoff meeting.
If that could happen at meetings all
over the country, I'd
be really happy.
So that still remains a key thing
for us to do while we're expanding
and enhancing these
community networks.
Jeanne, did you have?
>> Jeanne Drewes: I was going to
ask you about mutual aid agreements.
Is that what you're developing
for these small institutions
where you want them to work
together because you've really got
to have something formal?
>> Tom Clareson: Yes.
>> For that agreement
that they need to --
>> Tom Clareson: Yeah.
We're working toward that,
I can put it that way.
You know, I would say areas like
San Diego that has had an Alliance
for Response group
for years and years
where they put together a
really good mutual aid compact.
Those are some of the
models that are out there.
Seattle and other cities as well.
We are trying, in organizations
and cities like New Orleans,
before they've even started
working on Alliance for Response,
there were five or six
organizations there
that had been working
together on disaster planning.
And they have been
trying to figure out how
to put together a mutual
aid network there.
So I think that is going to
be one of the formal steps.
It may not be during this first
three-year grant that we are able
to get that far, but
I hope it will be
because that definitely is an end
goal that we have for the program.
Other questions or anything from
the webinar participants at all?
>> Jeanne Drewes: One question,
which is to confirm whether
LYRASIS is already connected
to the Heritage Emergency
National Task Force.
>> Tom Clareson: Yes.
We have, I'm a member.
And then there are other people
who are hoping to get training
and one person who has
been attending some
of the meetings as well.
So, yeah. We work with Heritage
Emergency National Task Force,
and certainly as part of
the board of the Foundation
for the American Institute for
Conservation, I work to make sure
that our members, if we
have disaster concerns,
are plugged into being
able to work within HR.
Any other questions?
If not, I would say, watch
this space, watch email to find
out about potential
grants, watch for some
of the community work
that's going on out there,
and thank you very much
for both your attention
and your questions today.
I really appreciate it.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.